we know first of all that today the fdp
spd and the greens decided to discuss
forming a government armand lotshit said
clearly that the cdu is available for
talks but the cdu did not have the best
election result i don't think i need to
add anything to that
german chancellor angela merkel speaking
there my first guest tonight sees the
erosion of popular support for the cdu
germany's traditional conservative big
tent party as a bad omen for europe in
an opinion piece in the new york times
this week author christopher caldwell
argues that with the cdu's loss in last
month's election a pillar of the
european order has collapsed he writes
that with the cdu's defeat something
larger than angela merkel's 16-year
tenure as german chancellor is coming to
an end
christopher caldwell joins us tonight
from washington d.c mr cardwell it's
good to have you on the program
the conservatives
does the cdu they're beating at the
ballot box
last month why is this not simply the
story of a political party that just
lost its connection with its voters
well i think it is that and um
you know when we say that it's a it's a
problem for europe it's a problem for
europe as it exists now but there's a
lot of dynamism in european politics and
people obviously do want to change
um
you know i uh there was a sort of a
conflict between the cdu represented a
couple of things it it represented
stability
um
uh and it represented familiarity
the the german voting public now is is
turning towards different things there
are certain
people who want more of an eu role in
what germany does there are certain
people who want less who want a more
traditional kind of sovereignty that
would be the afd there are certain
people who want
a little bit more attention to
climate change
now up till now
uh angela merkel had offered them um
a certain amount of familiarity and a
certain amount of seniority in in
governing structures
that that consoled them for a politics
with that was a little off of what young
people wanted but now
voters have shifted particularly young
people and we're seeing a different kind
of politics
you focus a lot in your article on
german chancellor angela merkel
she's been chancellor for 16 years she
outlasted what four u.s presidents
numerous french presidents uk prime
ministers and we were looking at the
leaders the leaders who have held on to
power as long as miracle are russians
vladimir putin and turkey's president
recep tayyip erdogan these are not
exactly the torchbearers of democracy
would you say that merkel maybe was in
power too long are 16 years in power
unhealthy for a
democracy um you know that's a
complicated question we've had you know
uh we had a president elected to
four terms um
there there have been a lot of um
uh european leaders elected many times
it can be but i don't know that it
necessarily was in this case merkel
would have been um re-elected most
likely um
had she run i think that her
her politics actually found an
interesting
middle ground i mean i i'm reminded a
little bit of um the 1957
cdu campaign slogan which was no
experiments merkel was a kind of
experimental politician but she had an
anti-utopian side
um like her her cdu forebears and so she
wound up with a with a slightly
experimental government that germans
wound up liking well let me ask you a
little bit about that you know she is
accused of
appropriating
the the center left and policies or even
the greens policies into her own cdu
policies which at the time many times
has been called ingenius but on election
day last month it proved to be
the worst thing she could have done do
you agree with that
um
this too is complicated i yes i think in
a way it was um the worst thing she
could have done um
but for a different set of reasons i you
know when when miracle started out there
was an idea of the cdu
that was still kind of intact which was
that it had a destiny
to be the right most party on the german
uh political spectrum that um and as
such it had a very very moderating
anchoring um
influence on on the country
merkel though um decided to use that as
a as a liberty to move to the center
assuming that that no one would take the
votes on the right away from her then
she had the immigration crisis of 2015
you had the afd began to stress
immigration in a very very
resounding straightforward way and she
proved wrong and you wound up with a
with almost a hundred people in the
bundestag who were to the right of what
germans were used to thinking of as
the right most edge of their politics
but mr carlo that was 2017 in this last
election the the afd they didn't do very
well especially in the federal
parliament
yeah they lost votes but um
you know they are now
they lost votes but they they have moved
there are a couple of things that are
that have
become apparent in this issue one is
they are a national party they're
getting um 10 in a lot of um
districts all across the country unlike
for instance the left party the other
thing is that they seem to have
um strongholds in a in a couple of
eastern
lender um um saxony and
thuringia so you're right it was not
you cannot draw a simple mathematical
equation and say everyone who left the
cdu wound up in the afd the way some
people thought you could in 2017.
um
but the the afd is is i would say
much more securely anchored than people
thought it would be five years ago well
let me ask you about merkel and her
conservatives this notion that
they have
been
too cozy with china for example and also
refusing to stop the nordstrom 2
pipeline with russia
the the greens for example who will most
likely be in the next german government
you know they are against nordstrom 2
and they are hawks when it comes to
china
do they not strengthen europe more than
miracles conservatives ever did
i think they strengthened the european
union the the greens have always been a
very um
firmly pro-european
party so for that matter have the um
has the cdu
um but there are certain stumbling
blocks on the way to
further
german
participation in europe and they're
mostly of a of a financial nature um
you know last year uh uh uh the spring
the spring of last year you had um
uh germany took part for the first time
in a jointly financed european bond for
the the kovid emergency funding that was
a um that was a major threshold for uh
angela merkel to cross i think that that
the greens are quite comfortable with it
i think the cdu is uncomfortable with it
and i think the free democrats are quite
uncomfortable with it and i think that
that will be
at the heart of a lot of the coalition
negotiations coming up yeah and since
we're speaking of european pillars and
eu summit today wrapped up with
disagreement on practically
every issue on the agenda and our europe
correspondent barbara basil she joins us
now from the summit venue in slovenia
barbara it's good to have you along
tonight before we discuss this eu summit
you've been listening to my discussion
with mr caldwell let me let me get your
reaction
um i would say to some points objections
your honor particularly the idea that
it's angela merkel's fault that the afd
developed on on the extreme right in
germany uh which center
ground political party in europe would
be able to sort of straddle the extremes
from the very right to the very sort of
more left and and sort of take it all in
and just pull it all together in in one
big vote it is impossible and we have
seen in many other european countries
that the political landscape has become
so scattered so fragmented look at the
netherlands look at scandinavia look at
italy
look at the total disappearance of the
traditional
parties in france for instance and it
becomes quite clear that the past is the
past and that we are just going into a
totally different political future that
demands different sets of compromises
that
may demand a different personality than
the one
that uncle merkel has very successfully
shown on the european stage for 16 years
and that is so this future is in an
unknown country and we will just have to
face it and there are many facets you
mentioned uh china the the foreign
policy of the eu will have to evolve it
it simply will have to otherwise um
there will
you will run into grave problems and
there are there is a long list of those
topics that just needs we need to be
tackled now and somebody else needs to
do that somebody other than angela
merkel mr carver what do you say about
that i mean what barbara is describing
here is is a german political system
that has become like
the rest of of western europe um
and
is it isn't that a good thing
uh you know i i i don't know i'm i'm
talking about angela merkel and not
about the system as a whole but i would
say that that that that
that in moving to the center i would say
that miracle actually abandoned that um
role of straddling the center
and to the right she what she did
embrace was yes i would say a more
european
um
logic there is a logic in a lot of
countries now of the grand coalition
the um
you know the the the macron movement the
republican march
is a sort of a coalition of of of groups
of the former
um uh
of of of former social democrats and um
former gaulists meeting in the center
the biden coalition to the extent that
it has picked up a few anti-trump
republicans is also uh a centrist
formation i quite agree about about the
logic of of of europe but i still think
there is a there are possibilities for
center-right and center-left parties let
me pull barbara back in barbara you know
you and i we spoke uh countless times in
the past five years um
after the brexit referendum mr caldwell
writes that angela merkel's 2015
decision to allow syrian refugees into
germany and i'm quoting him here drove
britain out of the european union is
that how it's seen
from where you're standing
let me stifle a little shrill squeak
here um because i believe that there are
there were many aspects
driving britain out of the european
union particularly from within the
united kingdom it was british
exceptionalism it was
of course the polish plumber and the
lithuanian truck driver that they would
in britain so urgently get back now who
were sort of
sort of painted black by a certain
populist strain in the conservative
party there were many aspects there was
particularly this one big lie by michael
gove let's remember who said that the
european union wanted to bring in turkey
into its folds and with it like millions
of turks who would then flood the united
kingdom that was the threat that was
painted on the wall and not the syrians
none of them ever made their way to the
uk so
i do disagree on that point christopher
very sorry to say so and um i believe
that angela merkel had
particularly nothing to do with it
because she looked at the british
government and she recognized that she
could not keep them that she
that you could not keep people from
traveling who really wanted to go on a
voyage and therefore she didn't invest
more and and more and more uh
heavily into
the project of keeping uh britain in the
eu she thought it couldn't be done and
yes she was right in the end it could in
fact not be done
let me let me just throw in one more
before we run out of time the issue of
the transatlantic world um mr caldwell
i'll ask you what is the weakest link
right now
in the transatlantic alliance is it a
germany without
miracle and the conservatives in power
or is it the united states with the
possibility of donald trump running for
president again in 2024
ah well it i i mean it could be um
it could be both or neither of those
things and a different thing i think
that right now
um the united states is in a very um
[Music]
it's in a very um
difficult um situation the um
you know um it's polarized as as i'm i'm
sure i don't have to tell you um but the
actual the logic of the of the governing
biden coalition is is is beginning to
break down he's um
he's following falling very quickly in
the polls
and it's not um certain that he can
bring the um left and the right wings of
his party
um together it's not sure that he can
it's not certain that he can perform
that
classic center-left straddling function
that is the role of a of a democratic
president so
you know whether that's going to be a a
long-term difficulty i really can't say
but
it's a problem right now
i'll let you um barbara get the final
word here what do you think is the
weakest link here
from the european viewpoint the the
weakest link at the moment are indeed
the united states because it seems so
very uncertain where politics will go
there whereas looking at the likely
successor in the german
chancellery olaf schultz i mean he is as
lacking in in
sort of
temper and temperament and
all the all these sort of
arts the political arts
as angel america was um he is a sort of
very solid very serious almost a dollar
kind of personality and he will
certainly keep the ship steady he is not
somebody who goes off on
on a voyage to utopia he is not somebody
who will make experiments uh that people
can't follow
so it is going to be very straight on
from here but it will be different in a
way it will be more modern and they will
try to look more to the future and to
anticipate the future problems more so
it will be different but in a way the
same and i think there's going to be
plenty of opportunities for us to get
together again and discuss this this is
a story that has some very long legs on
it barbara vaselforis in slovenia and
christopher caldwell in washington d.c
to both of you we appreciate your time
and the excellent discussion tonight
thank you
thank you